what do we need to know about Shamari
what you need to know about Shamari is
Jamari is a free spirit she speaks her
mind she's a little short thing she's a
mom of twin boys and she has a lot of
fire in her she's super fun Temari DeVoe
has officially joined the ladies of the
Real Housewives of Atlanta so eg had her
co-star as a breakdown what you need to
know about their new magician Shamari is
married to running the bow from new
addition Jamari was a member of the
group black
[Music]
hey hey boys your way and it's not being
mature
I don't know if you all know the song
boom like a 808 it was hot back in the
early 2000s I wrote a remix today
[Music]
we were really cool like me Mari our
group members I've known it for a long
time
stimulated to me where she already had
you know some career success in her life
she's been a movie yes Shamari and her
group members were Gabrielle unions
squad and bring it on now you know she's
joining her reality TV and I don't you
know I keep telling her I don't know how
she's gonna feel once it actually goes
on-air
you know that first year is like a
shocker you know but she'll be fine it's
one thing to live it it's another thing
to have to relive it with the world one
exactly Shamari is very unexpected and
very different for the show in every in
a refreshing way Samara is a firecracker
she's definitely a bomb yeah I could say
that she comes in that little package
got a lot inside she says a lot doesn't
she's very honest you know sometimes she
could be a wild child you'll get very
open person no one drinks in it no I
love I love some more she's right I like
Shamari a lot okay and I think you guys
are gonna really enjoy her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]